beaucoup de personnes qui ont soins n'a
pas passé à passer une heure une heure
et demie dans son auto-évaluation repose
sur le fait que jusqu'à 60% des usagers
quotidiens du tunnel soit 72000
automobilistes devront adapter leurs
habitudes et choisir le transport en
commun du moins pendant les trois ans
que durant les travaux chose certaine
loto solo s'avère la pire des solutions
et les travaux ils doivent permettre de
prolonger de 40 ans la durée de vie du
tunnel emprunter par 120000
automobilistes chaque jour dès le 31
octobre jour de l'Halloween les
automobilistes devront donc composer
avec une voix ouverte en direction de la
Rive-Sud deux voies en direction de
Montréal bref l'ensemble des travaux
devrait multiplier par 4 le temps de
traverser le pont tunnel de Montréal
vers la Rive-Sud et par trois en sens
inverse qu'on a mis en place des mesures
comme la gratuité
de certaines lignes d'autobus on ajoute
à ça des voies réservées plus de
navettes vers les stations de métro les
stationnements incitatifs pour bien des
gens ça va être quand même assez
compliqué mais c'est sûr
à partir du mois de novembre c'est pas
facile mais on n'a pas le choix une
chose que j'habite pas sur la rue
les camionnettes qui constituent 13% de
la chalandage dans le tunnel craignent
une rupture d'approvisionnement
certainement à certains moments il
pourrait lui avoir des ruptures de la
chaîne logistique et de
l'approvisionnement sur sur ces
périodes-là d'ici là le gouvernement
recommande plus que jamais aux usagers
de se trouver un plan B et de connaître
les mesures à leur disposition à la page
québec.ca la fontaine pour survivre à la
congestion ici Gabriel prou Radio-Canada
Montréal